so
oh my gosh i did it hello everyone
welcome i wasn't sure if i'd be able to
get this to work because i've never done
these before
but uh we're here i might need to make
myself a little bit smaller
i'm very excited
i think the thing's just about to start
oh
does that happen don't bother on me now
come on mate it's not my internet
i guess something's happened to their
stream
i guess i should refresh just in case
we'll see oh [ __ ] it literally cut off
the start okay here we go
the one with the cat i don't know what
it was called it's like a land full of
robots
type thing let's do this i forgot about
it i hope we see
miles morales gameplay today
really really really want that
price would be really nice you could do
it right now no okay
i guess we'll have to wait for that
that's cool that's cool that's fine
interesting why huh bug snacks probably
bug snacks
demon souls
he kind of keep
i still look like the missiles
you see a fire in a video game you think
it's a souls game
oh stream's too low i can turn you guys
up
oh [ __ ] the final fantasy rumor is
potentially true
yeah let me know if that's too loud now
you guys
i didn't want to drown myself out it's a
difficult mix
so that should be okay will not
relinquish their mother crystal easily
it's still too loud this will be a
bitter fight
you should not be out of doors we have
discussed this
sure it's still telling joshua fix it
okay i think there's like a longer delay
on youtube than normal for some reason
maybe because it's an event i don't know
i am joshua
but yeah feel free to tell me totally
cool i'm swoon all right
final fantasy this is the one that was
rumored everyone expected this to happen
i'm always gonna play it looks great
did you not place your
what accent is that without the blessing
of the mother crystal we cannot defend
our realm from the spread of the blight
i mean this looks amazing like this is a
beautiful
i'm also into the settings
some castlevania vibes
oh all right damn okay all right attack
on titan
that's impossible
this is it looks really good uh the
video resolution of the ps5 stream is
max res so there's no issues with that
you guys that is definitely 1080
it's as high as it can has shaped our
history
so long enough
[Music]
i'll kill you
if it's the last thing i do into it
great smart start with that when that
was the one that everyone knew about
looks beautiful i'm into the dark
fantasy
theme of that cool with it yeah
looks great um bummer that we saw it on
pc though and it
is worth noting i guess playstation
console exclusive also on pc so that one
won't be on xbox
good to know price
price price price it's not gonna happen
for ages
uh yeah i feel like i'll have to update
the sound
for every game because the levels are
already inconsistent
so i might just have to play around with
it for you guys sorry about that
it happens
thank you for that good to know
it's too cold to change out he is yes
yes give me gameplay yes
damn i'm gonna upgrade your monster just
to
do that because i can on youtube there
we go
this is currently the next gen game that
i want to play the most
i love insomniac i love spider-man i got
it
um
tommy acts incredible honestly because
it's also russian clank
uh so ratchet clank is the one that i'm
most interested in technically that i
think is like the most
most next-gen game we've seen but i just
want to see gameplay from this like are
we do we got new locations
dude i am so filling your suit with snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah
you know just in case it's gonna be fine
i just got goosebumps this looks amazing
this is my favorite part of living in
harlem
pop-up street fair best food in the city
awesome music
man look at the reflections
i should get back into mixing yeah it's
been a while
are you kidding me
what do you think about rio morales are
you gonna vote for her
still hard to think of mama it's a lot
of characters on screen too she's been a
teacher my whole life
oh my god rallying people educating them
making sure they don't throw things at
each other i'm like shook
hi i'm brian horton creative director at
insomniac games stunning we're excited
marvel spider-man miles morales our
story picks up
one year after the events of the first
game and we find miles new home
harlem is in danger trouble bruised
while miles mom
rio morales leads an election rally a
war between the devious energy
corporation roxanne
and the underground a high-tech criminal
army led by the tinkerer
starts to break out cool in this
gameplay sequence capture on playstation
yeah
sending the rally into chaos in a fight
that spills onto the brainwave
i know what the hashtag for this event
is ps5 showcase
new form holy [ __ ] man
oh thanks ryan i appreciate it yeah i
tend to you said i look nice i do dress
up for
the comfort zone shoot each other which
is stupid
but uh it makes me feel like e3 is a
little bit more real
i've got a nice skirt on
we're after the new form ignore
everything else
that's a lady
get rid of him then grab as much as you
can carry
[Music]
i mean this all looks very cinematic
it's not so gameplay but i guess the
whole game does look that way but this
is this is
this is a cutscene you said it was game
[Music]
god damn
this is so pretty
why is he wearing an xbox shot that's
the wrong conference fam
okay okay okay
i have to stop this
i just keep paying attention to the
lighting i keep saying with like
with next-gen we aren't going to see
graphical upgrades
updates be as dramatic as they used to
be but what we are going to see change
is water hair lighting things like
explosions and fire
obviously which i adore it's so so good
so i'm just trying to pay a lot of
attention to the lighting and frankly
there's a lot of lighting going on here
this is gorgeous
like even the bridge looks really pretty
god electric powers are really cool
oh heck
no no no no no
the bus
just the the most spider-man thing ever
he's got to save a bus from uh
from falling up a bridge classic
thank you man
[Music]
cool
[Music]
i can stop this
but he got to be pretty strong to pull
this one off is all i'm saying
this looks awesome and there's so much
going on um
i'd be very interested to see
side-by-side comparisons with spider-man
ps4
i feel like there's more on screen but
our memories of video games are so
untrustworthy
can't wait i cannot wait
like no matter what anyway i couldn't
but damn yes the number one next-gen
game that i want to play right now 100
you'll love to see it
i hated that they did these with the
last ones i don't like the intercutted
things
just you know i don't know why
like i didn't like it but white annoys
me so much okay
ah ah all right we've been expecting
this for a while
magic both beautiful and powerful
binds together our long history
that common bond we share is the legacy
of hogwarts
i loved the original harry potter games
they're bad but my sister and i played
the hell out of those backgrounds
it was on pc it was during the ps2 era i
believe quite possibly
the future of the wizarding world
so we know this is supposed to be like
in uh every
rpg ever since gameplay in this castle
tells the story of witches and wizards
who came before
here you will meet lifelong friends and
grow into your own magical abilities
in the classrooms of the world's most
this is all cinematic versions
but what is
there is a larger world beyond
world filled with dangers you can't yet
imagine an ancient knowledge
i feel like all the humans so far have
looked like sims characters like been a
bit cartoony
but then it's strange
your potential
is limitless
but what form will it take
[Music]
i wonder if it'll play like fable like
the journey
will reveal what you stand for
[Music]
the choices you make now
will define the legacy of hogwarts
hey very cool but what is game
what is game how do i play game it's
always my question
it being avalanche is like particularly
interesting
like i can't even imagine how the
avalanche formula fits into
that game hmm
hi everyone i'm dan vondrag creative
director at raven
one of our goals as developers is to
bring the game world to life unlike
anything you've ever experienced and the
playstation 5 is making that happen
with the powerhouse console we've been
able to significantly enhance the
overall experience
from what you see in the world how it
feels in your hands to what you hear
around you
in black ops cold war you will be
transported to the year 1981
in the middle of one of the most
dangerous times the world has ever known
the height of the cold war i don't know
why the following is a portion of the
first campaign
we've been given the name of a high
value target linked to the iran hostage
crisis
but in true black ops style nothing is
as it seems
take a look um i feel like it's because
it often looks too similar but i guess i
guess we'll see i guess we'll see
kasim is out of the picture how long
before we get a rash
the team arrived in turkey a few hours
ago they should be in position shortly
is he cgi rocky scarlet they actually
don't look as cgi this time around
um yeah i feel like cod will be a great
um
look at the graphics that's what i'll
say airfield's just up ahead
let's go find this [ __ ]
priority sound design call of duty is
like consistently second to none
the effort they put in i've interviewed
those teams
about like the amount of different
microphones they put on one gun and the
amount of different ways that they shoot
it like
they go hard
it's uh it's a lot of work to get
everything feeling authentic
it's like ground zeroes
[Music]
cold war is a cool setting not available
gonna tweet out that i'm streaming this
during call of duty
is just the one that i really interested
in you just diced everyone in a truck
that's got to be a rash hold fire not
least interested in i just never i just
feel like they're marketing off and
blends together is my beef okay that's
our man
take him out
i assume that doesn't really happen
[Music]
and the lighting looks good on this too
this actually doesn't look as impressive
as i would have thought graphically
like not compared to miles morales
it just looks a bit flat
give me more of those
said michael bay
that's pretty cool
do the frames look something maybe they
do there's something
off about it
again it could be the stream it's so
hard to say but i i feel like my issue
is
i mean i feel like it'll look better
because call of duty usually looks
better
strange i don't know just
look like close i hope you enjoyed that
sneak peek at the campaign for black ops
cold war
there are many more twists and turns
along the way as you begin to unravel
the truth and we can't wait for you to
play it soon
in addition to the story campaign cold
war features the next generation of
multiplayer online combat
and an all new awesome zombies
experience today i have the special
honor to announce on behalf of my
friends at treyarch
that the playstation community doesn't
have to wait to play multiplayer
starting this friday playstation players
will be able to play the multiplayer
alpha exclusively
on playstation 4. and for those of you
that are watching at home on your ps4
you can pre-load the experience starting
tomorrow we can't wait to see you online
friday
and through the weekend enjoy the rest
of the show
[Music]
don't worry you guys i'm tweeting a joke
don't worry about it
it happens don't worry about it there we
go so don't know what the actual hashtag
is i'm using ps5 showcase but
other people i guess it's just hashtag
ps5 maybe
who knows
okay another video game i'm liking the
pacing of this i will say
all clear so far i feel like this is the
best
um chris what the hell
take him away uh
so far in terms of pacing for sure i
still hate those little institutions
though
capcom presents marvel comics
obviously it's not actually
in life and in death we give
glory i've been looking forward to
seeing the bell
tolls for us all fyi if you didn't know
they're coming
again
it looks so outlasty and i like i was
worried about resident evil 7 looking
that different to other resident evil i
was like i don't know if i'm going to
like it
[Applause]
quit being so paranoid
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to pick berries for her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark
cold silence the bush is empty
yet determined to find the berries the
rascal broke free of mother's grasp and
vanished into the trees
okay mothers worried
cries faded fast as the girl ran on over
vine
under branch
if there are frame drops just for the
record it's not on my end i had zero
drop
frames
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just a local tale
this is such a i don't know what they're
doing with this game very interested
like there are there's a lot going on
you know what i'm saying
i wonder if we'll get a release day
buddy
i don't feel like i've won window shop
away much beyond what we already knew
from this
2021 i mean it's good to like have the
lineup of stuff that's coming tony what
do you mean
or if they already announced that i
completely forgot that's my bad but i
felt like they hadn't
it's all right it's all right it totally
did look like colorado cara
oh yes this game yes definitely
[Music]
it's so i stylish the studio
you want out of a time loop you gotta
learn how it works
black reef is a puzzle and each
visionary is a different piece
i can't wait to play this here's eagle
i am a respected scientist i've done so
many loops i've learned to run circles
around him
i also really like this uh game to
function this way
like uh it's not a direct
parallel but say like a hotline miami
for example
where it's like figure out how
everything works and where everyone is
and then kill them all like
they'll kill you and then you'll get a
little bit further and you'll figure
more out
post void which they didn't know the
gameplay of racism
i've tried taking this area of learning
as you're killing me and then when
you're watching
like i i'm super there's never enough
time i go after one
another lives because right now half an
island away
a different visionary is throwing his
knightly cannibal masquerade
alexis dawson everybody shut up
this is my jam igor is a big fan
yet somehow he never makes it to the
party
something keeps him home gold you're
there
buddy here's the invite to the party
this game looks so
here's why egor blew it off he made some
kind of scientific breakthrough that
morning
i did it i did it it works daddy makes
more unless i get there first
[Music]
i'm just so into the concept and the
style and just
damn man like this is the kind of game
that feels like it was made for me
no breakthrough no reason for igor not
to drink his disappointment with alexis
now i got a shot at killing them both at
the same time
oh i'm talking about
definitely a little bit by yourself
i love it man i love yeah like it says
the loop is knowledge i love the
that learning process i think it rules
like having that be a loop of like you
learning and figuring it out
uh it's the same kind of style
eight targets on my list every one of
them with grand
plans for eternal life to break the loop
so i gotta break the rules clock's
ticking
and you just ran out of time you keep
forgetting cult
i'm not like those other idiots
only got one name on my list yours
oh great that's way earlier than i
expected
[Music]
oh god that game looks so good
i cannot wait for it cannot wait
like honestly i'm more excited about
that than i am about ratchet and clank
and miles morales but i guess like
because it's not
coming soon um i guess not that far away
but damn
um
if that positions were switched
would our fates be different
would i have your life and your mind
you a demon oh [ __ ]
[Music]
okay it was like this devil may cry well
what is it
i mean that's cool
[Music]
i still haven't finished that game i
really should i really should
rest in peace
[Music]
the stream quality for this one looks
bad
presently
again another one where you need like
side by side it looks the same to me
oh well that's nice available digitally
at launch i've never seen that
specification before
but okay still cool with it
[Music]
oh thank you matthew welcome to being a
member
[Music]
you've already seen this right
what are they doing did those fugitive
morons burn
down their own hearts we definitely are
getting a lot of games that we've
already
said i will say that much that's exactly
what it looks like
which really only stands out
yeah i'm still so happy about that
deathly trailer hi i'm lauren lanning
creative director of vodka only stands
out because we don't usually we're
excited to bring you an all-new
exclusive trailer from the game
here our unlikely hero abe finds himself
fresh off the back of freeing his people
from the nefarious republic is like the
least likely the journey is
to be continued but soon discovers it
only just because
the stakes are higher the threats are
larger the obstacles are more devious
and it's all made possible by the power
of playstation five
again
you may have just dropped for a second
i got an obs warning that i've never
seen before
wait here hey why'd you hold up i could
go for a sandwich right now we got to
get out of here
come on let's get out of here my tummy's
growling
you guys have to catch up did the drop
happen where's the drop
okay back i don't know i don't know
okay
[Music]
it's weird i've never seen obs give me
that kind of error before
[Music]
gregory your friends are worried about
you
they're here with me please come out
gregory i may have lost my temper what's
it worth always having a scary
young girl
it's been such a difficult day for all
of us
why don't you come out and we can play a
game together
it won't happen again oh it is five
nights at freddy's
i like just assumed it was something
that was trying to be like five nights
at freddy's but it absolutely is five
nights at freddy's
gregory be still
i think she's found us this is a good
trailer
the tone of that trailer was sick very
cool
[Music]
nice
[Music]
i have actually looked into the um sorry
uh
harry four agent said because girls are
scary i've actually looked into the
psychology of it oh hang on
you guys it's totally gta 6.
[Music]
i misunderstood um apparently the thing
that makes
little girls scary specifically uh
is um something about innocence being
corrupted it's like it's supposed to be
a psychological thing
oh this is for sure demon sauce
100 sauce look at you
i guess we knew blue point was on that
yeah that was already known
oh she looks pretty
girl
oh my god this is like
you like made a souls game look pretty
like blood bones pretty but in a
disgusting way
this is like environmentally
like i want to be there i'm not like
like uncomfortable you know
holy [ __ ]
you're making it look too easy though
family
is that a little animation there got
some drop frames on the stream that's
all right that's all right
it's so weird without a ui though like
is that going to be an option is that
what you're telling me
that i can play it without without the
hud
this is beautiful
ah
it's it looks way too easy though like i
don't know why you've done this
like it's a strange choice to make this
look this easy
it's either hey they made it easier it
seems unlikely
b they've decreased the difficulty for
the pubs
of getting through a demo to show off
the environments all right can you get
slowed it now please
that's like a little bit better but i
guess even without having the ui so
without you know just having our health
balls you don't even really get an idea
look at the blood
oh my gosh
little like you can see his own breath
bro this is beautiful
stunning but it does look like
it was always easy until the boss look i
did play demon sauce
um but like back when i came out i
couldn't
tell you what the tutorial area looks
like anymore i don't remember it ever
being easy
i don't think doctors like to use four
different thoughts i guess when you
first play that
are rather easy to learn how to play but
i guess yeah
it's possible to one hit
people just an interesting choice to
show it that way
absolutely looks stunning beautiful
looks amazing uh
caleb can you imagine a free reckoning
had that amount of love and carrot put
into it that's gotta be like one of the
best
like remasters i've ever seen is how
pretty that was that was
stunning man beautiful
[Music]
i'm excited to play it again too because
i didn't finish it um
oh yeah i think i put in like five six
hours i was just talking to someone
about it yesterday
i was like is it going to be bug snacks
they have had some really good trailers
lately
um but i don't play the game
i thought the
i'm doing an instagram don't mind me
okay i did want to hear about uh some
services from them is that what this is
gonna be
okay can you kill something that big
and that game you telling me that these
are free on places
right now that we tell me
that they're actually rivaling game paws
is that what this is is that what this
is
[Applause]
one of my favorite games my name is
marius my name is
are you telling me how are you telling
me that all of these games come with
your
playstation is how we tell
is that
[Music]
i had to stop playing it because the ai
was so bad but not a lot of people have
that experience
it's time
those are some good games dog
okay okay that's actually really cool
that's actually really cool
that is not a um
everything type situation it's not it's
not
a game pass but that's awesome uh
okay wait though in comparison doesn't
that mean that it's saying that you only
get back it's compatible if you play for
pay for playstation plus which where
xbox is concerned you automatically have
which makes it less cool
so i'm glad it exists but it is
technically locking disks you already
own
behind a paywall rather than just giving
you the backwards compatibility if i'm
reading that correctly
[Music]
happy to see it but
but uh still it still makes
that subscription a lot better in any
case
it's not quite gameplay
[Music]
look we get it you're very sleek got
lots of curves
i might not be reading that right i'm
not sure i'll have to
um figure out what that's about
how much how much are they
that's uh okay 500 and 400.
[Music]
there you go
pretty much what we expected
checks out glad it happened so now you
know
thank you all for joining us today all
right you've been part of this amazing
journey okay
it's your passion as fans of gaming that
drives us to deliver a truly new
generation of experiences on ps5
everyone i did expect 100 we appreciate
your continued support
we look forward to you getting your
hands on ps5
very soon good cool with it to close
let me leave you with one more quick
look
this has got to be something unannounced
what's it gonna be what's it gonna be
the time draws near
bro
bro you serious bro bro you serious
oh my god
you must prepare yourself
i did not expect that today
oh my gosh oh my gosh
that's it though damn
i was so curious if they do something
today for that i didn't expect that to
be next
year holy [ __ ]
oh my god
that's insane
damn i feel like this is a really good
conference this is one of my favorites
of all of them so far
i don't know if everyone else has the
same read on it it's so hard to tell i
never know until i go on to twitter and
then i'm like how does everyone feel
about it
and then sometimes it's completely
different to what i expect like the lost
playstation conference i was like
this one fantastic
[Music]
fearless
there's a lot to process so what's a
process
when can we pre-order they said they'd
give us some time marcus so
i would think pretty soon maybe it'll be
friday
getting a bunch of text my guess is
because i've got a wall
that's so many texts yup
everybody knows how much i love it
all right i probably have to run i will
let this end but i have to go right
inside gaming immediately
do my job um ryan the launch title i'm
still most excited about is miles
morales
and ratchet clank from a tech
perspective but overall um
death loop man death loop was the
highlight of that for me
all right you guys i have to go back to
work thank you for joining me it's the
first time i've ever done one of these
um yeah it was fun
so yeah i'll leave it up and
gotta go back to work i will see you
guys next time
you